Mike Pompeo joins me now Mr secretary
before we get into that I would like
your comment on uh the pentagon's uh we
have our our our secretary of defense
who could only muster a two-line
statement about what happened to our
troops over the weekend a r you know he
had to read the lines in front of them
sitting across the table from the NATO
Secretary General your reaction to that
tonight you know when I first watched it
la I was I was appalled at the lack of
emotion about the loss of the three
soldiers frankly you add the two Navy
Seals that's five in just the last
couple of weeks great Americans no
longer with us and he was reading a
statement as if he was reading from the
dictionary um I just find that
disturbing uh but more importantly um
the policies that have resulted from
this secretary defense and this
president have led precisely to the
place we find ourselves today and while
they talk about not wanting World War
III they talk about want not not wanting
escalation it is moments like that that
the hayatullah watches or the shishin
Ping watches and he says I can roll
these guys and to date I I would argue
they certainly have done that uh your
reaction now to what we're learning
about this UN agency and the Hamas
attacks connection are you shocked by
this or not really given some of the
history with these un
workers L among the least surprising
breaking news moments of the last three
years I they
we have known for a long time our CIA
has known for a long time that unra was
deeply connected to the folks that
operate Hamas and the leadership that
the UN there was a corrupt organization
providing uh resources to Hamas instead
of trying to Feed and Fuel the gazen
people um we saw this in the Trump
Administration the bid Administration
reversed our policy we stopped funding
these guys and the the bid
Administration restored it and you can
precisely see the result these these are
not inevitabilities as the bid
Administration would suggest you what
happened on October 7th what happened to
our soldiers in Jordan this past week
the these are not inevitable things when
America fails to do the basic idea fails
to execute the basic idea of building a
strong military drawing red lines and
then defending them this is exactly what
happens Laura oh it's a it's a
heartbreak we lose those seals now we
lose these three there are apparently
some horrific injuries uh of our troops
who were sleeping uh when this attack
took place we all remember what happened
in 1983 in Lebanon uh with
242 Marines I believe who died in that
attack uh but secretary Pompeo we expect
more from a secretary defense after
after a weekend like this this I mean
it's it's a
heartbreak Lord my wife Susan will tell
you that every morning when I would wake
up when I was a CI director Secretary
State I was thinking about where my my
folks in my Embassy safe were my guys on
the ground at the CIA safe this was a
central focus of what we did it's one of
the reasons we wanted to ensure we had
deterrence we did pretty damn good work
for four years and now we've lost that
very deterrence that we had built up on
in the Trump Administration and I I I
fear that we're not at the end of this
we are simply just at the beginning
secretary Pompeo thank you so much great
to see you as always hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else